um okay hi I hope you guys can all hear
me
so I'm joy I said now I'm a developer at
anaconda I work on some of the different
open-source tools that we have going on
there so I work on intake and most of my
time I spend on the Hall of is tool so
we'll be talking more about that later
this talk is not about a particular tool
or a particular content area it's meant
to be more I talked about how to do like
about your workflow and how to ingest
data get it in a workable shape and
visualize it even large data and how to
deploy dashboards so hopefully we'll be
able to cover that in 40 minutes or
whatever so I'm gonna be talking about a
lot of different tools mostly intake
panel and HV plot but all these other
tools will be used either behind the
scenes I'll try to call it out when it's
happening but you don't have to use all
of these tools you can take one they're
designed to work well together but you
can just take one if you want that one
and use it on so and that's totally fine
we won't be said so this this talk is
gonna have three different data sets the
first one's gonna be anaconda package
download data so that's tabular time
series data its categorical it's stored
as park' files there's two it's too big
to fit in memory and just all the
downloads that happen of all the
different packages from anaconda org
satellite imagery which is raster data
it's geo-referenced stored as g OT f and
then locations of trees in Philadelphia
which is also tabular geo-reference
joy's geo json it's like I think it's a
hundred thousand trees or something
so the first one we're gonna talk about
is the Anaconda package download data so
this is data is publicly available it's
interesting but it's daily park' files
and you can find there's a link to it
here and I can I'll post these slides
they're up online if you want to that
URL is probably small for you but I'll
put it on the slack so they're at this
at URL this repo and this in this case
we're going to be talking mostly about
intake and panel so we're gonna be
making this dashboard which is a panel
dashboard and it allows people to
interact with your data so and to say
it's at the beginning but the point of
this talk is to explore your data
visualize it and then talk about other
people to explore it who maybe are less
technically advanced or maybe just don't
want to spend the time digging into the
code but you want to expose some
features that you think are interesting
to other people allow them to explore
that on their own but in this guided
dashboard e-way so that's kind of a
motivating reason for this is that you
might be comfortable getting in a
notebook and exploring it but for others
it's often easier to put it in a
dashboard so panel is a tool that allows
you to do that fairly easily so before
we get to that though we have to start
with coding in our data so we're gonna
do that using intake intake is a data
cataloguing tool it provides a way of
abstraction between the data and the
user so that allows the data provider to
distribute the data and the user doesn't
have to know that much about what about
how the data is stored and where the
data is stored and all these things that
ultimately they don't really care about
it captures the pic the dependencies of
a particular data set so you can capture
that all and we'll talk about that more
when you get to that part and it reduces
the copy and pasting between notebooks
so instead of having a top cell be this
huge wrong
Pano's we'd CSV with all these different
options you just have a simple one-liner
from intake and you don't have to think
about it so we're gonna start by talking
about that
more detail okay notebook time so this
notebook as I mentioned is bigger is
that good for people more okay so this
notebook is available and the github
repository so we're going to start by
using tasks and we're gonna show how you
can read the park a file using tasks
from s3 this is all one good you can use
globs it's fine you can do a similar
thing using intake just using intake dot
open parquet with the file and storage
options and store it as a desk array so
the output from these two things are
identical so that's not that doesn't
seem very useful right that's fine it's
the same thing but um the real benefit
that you get from intake is when you
store the metadata and the options that
you're feeding into this read command in
a catalog so this is what an intake
catalog looks like this one's a little
involved but basically all they need to
have is a URL path where the data is
actually stored and the type of driver
that we're gonna use to read it so
that's the that's kind of the most
essential part of this and then this one
also has some different user parameters
like year and month and then it also has
this cache so we're going to cache the
data locally so we can access it more
easily so now all that data is
abstracted into a gamma file human
readable you can distribute it it's so
it's up online so we're actually pulling
it from github directly and we can open
that catalog and then we can get the get
the data for the whole month into a desk
data frame in just a one-liner so we are
looking at that catalog now because
we're talking about how intake works but
from the user perspective they never
need to really look at that catalog like
they're happy they've got their data for
the month so you can also read straight
to pandas using dot read instead of did
ask if your data is small enough
to have that work and then the other
method you can use is you can package
your data as a condo package so in this
case you guys can go if you want kinda
install this package from the intake
channel and then you can you don't have
to mess around with the reading the
catalogue at all you can just it'll be
in the intake built in catalog itself
and you can just call it directory so in
this case they don't need to know the
URL they just have the data in the data
package in their environment in their
condo environment and then they can read
the data in the same way that we talked
about above so there's a couple of
different ways to use it you can choose
which one best suits you or or not but
this this one I think is particularly
interesting because you can store all
the dependencies you can store the you
know the dependency on fast parquet or
tasks and intake itself in that data
package and then you just have it and
it's really probably the most
straightforward way and the data I
should mention is still on s3 like this
data is not in the package itself
there's just a link to it and then once
you once you have the data frame you can
just do the normal things you are going
to do with your data you just carry on
with your life like it's no different
it's just a way to load in data so you
can you know you might want to compute
how many pandas having downloads of
pandas there are from the Anaconda
Channel or something or you might want
to look at Python 3 versus price on to
usage so you can explore this as a
binder link on the repo you can do what
you will
so now we are going to talk about
creating the dashboard so panel has a
relatively new package that we've been
developing in the hall of his ecosystem
so it provides but it builds on bouquet
and it vendors in bouquet and so it has
this really solid foundation so it's
it's a relatively new API or set of
api's but it has a really strong basis
in a bouquet
so provides api's for interactivity
we'll talk about some of those there's a
there's a bunch of different ones is
pretty complete panel Docs that you can
find online these Google Python panel
not just panel doesn't do anything of it
you don't but that but um so it allows
others to explore your data without
writing any code which can be really
helpful and it also doesn't make you
write any JavaScript although we are
gonna write a little JavaScript in this
case but you don't have to ok so so in
order to create the download dashboard
we're gonna first load the data using
intake this is just a little get the
last month thing and then this is our
our class that we're setting up to use
of panel so this is one way in which you
can use panel is a parameterised class
so we're using this in this case because
we have a bunch we have a bunch of state
that we're going to want to keep track
of so that's a really good use case for
a class so we wanted to keep track of
the package name that the person has
inputted the the version and then
there's like the grouping that they have
chosen on their dashboard so those are
going to be things that the user is
going to select then we're gonna store
them on the class and we're going to
show various outputs based on what
they've chosen for those parameters so
we can go into this more later if we
have time and you guys are interested
but these are basically a bunch of
methods that we're setting up and they
either do something or they return
something and they are all decorated
with this params dot depends and they
are decorated with particular parameters
that the user will define so this one
updates the data that we're going to use
so it subsets the data to just be about
that one particular package that they've
selected and it depends on the package
attribute
so there's a bunch of these because I
got a little involved with this and then
you can set up a layout for how you're
going to display all these parameterize
objects so when you have the class has
these different has these different
properties and then we're gonna display
them all in this kind of like row grit
row column framework you don't have to
use this row grid wet a row column way
there's other ways to do this but it's
just when you make a dashboard and then
keep adding to it you often end up with
this kind of thing so now we have our
dashboard which we can view in the
notebook right here you can try a
different package and it'll we render
you can group by different things and
change the bar chart you can select
which version you want and only you look
at that version and this so this is the
type of thing that is kind of like
useful to package owners so this is
something that can be used without
without accessing the notebook by by
serving this dashboard at a URL so if
you go to the github repo you can find a
binder link to the app itself and you'll
just it'll drop you right into this app
running on binder okay so now we are
going to jump to the next case study
which is satellite imageries and
locations of trees so i said we do three
different data sets but these these two
I'm going to do together because they
overlay on top of each other nicely so
these is this in this one we're going to
be mostly talking about HV plot so we're
going to be working up to creating this
dashboard which is actually work
statically the one we just looked at a
minute ago works if you have a running
Python kernel because it has two subsets
the data
and that can only happen in Python but
this one is we're just going to be doing
sliders and adjusting which players I
turned on and turn off so that can be
done using javascript so and that allows
it to be served as a static URL so you
can find it at this link it's just my
github and then heat entries and it's a
fully functional a little static thing
that you can mess around with and it
doesn't have a running kernel okay so
we're gonna be mostly talking about HB
pot in this section so it mimics the dot
pot API that you get in pandas but
instead of generating map pollute output
it generates holo views objects and
they're rendered in Boca so that's a lot
of different names of packages I just
said to you but basically that the
result is that you can do a lot of
different grouping and aggregating and
overlaying very easily that's how that's
what whole views gives you and then
boquete gives you the ability to zoom in
zoom out have hover tips and just have
this really nice interactive experience
on the JavaScript side so it also
integrates with geo views and data
shader geo views gives you the geo
referencing data shader allows you a
great to the pixel so you don't over
plot your data if you have large volumes
of point data or if you have really
dense raster data you can aggregate to
the pixel as well so you don't crash
your browser so right now it's repot
supports pandas geo pandas tasks x-ray
streams and network x which i always
forget to include
so we'll start by looking at just the
raster data so this is the Landsat
imagery that we're gonna be looking at
so this is the imports we're gonna
import it using intake and just a little
background on Landsat imagery it's
distributed in the swatch swatches so
there's paths and rows and each path row
is a is called a scene and those scenes
are captured at a particular like
frequency or a particular cadence so you
might get like one every month or
something and they're all publicly
available on Google Cloud storage and
AWS s3 I mean so when you take though
each Landsat scene is composed of these
different frequencies these different
bands that capture particular
information about the earth so for this
case we're gonna be looking at the land
surface temperature so we're going to
calculate the land surface temperature
from a couple of these different bands
so for that we're gonna use the red band
the near-infrared and the thermal
infrared bands so we're gonna be using
those bands and we're gonna be doing
some calculations on them and then we're
going to be getting a land surface
temperature from that so we can get the
intake catalog which will read here so
this is what the intake catalog looks
like for this case so it's a Landsat
band we're using the raster i/o driver
so that caused you to read in raster
data really easily you can see these all
these geo tips so we're gonna take the
four bands that we're interested in the
four five ten and eleven and then we're
going to concatenate them and we're
going to allow the user to specify the
path throw and product ID that they're
interested in so in this case I'm
choosing area above Philadelphia for
this particular date that was very hot
because
I don't think I mentioned what we're
trying to accomplish in this particular
case study but we're trying to look at
the heat the surface temperature and
compare that with the color of roofs and
then and the location of street trees to
try and see if there's a relationship
between surface temperature roof color
and shoe trees so the hypothesis is that
dark-colored roofs are hotter and if
there's more street trees nearby that
that mitigates that so we're gonna get a
particular path row and product ID and
we get a data source from intake and
then we can read it into task the same
way as we did before using dot two desk
so now we have an x-ray object and the
x-ray object doesn't isn't yet read into
memory actually it is but it doesn't
have to be it can also be a task array
and then we can subset to a region of
interest so we are since this is geo
data on this x-ray object read in with
rest area there's a coordinate reference
system so we can take that coordinate
reference system and we can use Carta PI
to convert it to a CRS object and then
we can read in geo JSON of the
neighborhoods in Philadelphia to subset
to that area so here's a this is a geo
Jason that contains all the
neighborhood's we read it in using geo
panas and then we get the bounds and I'm
gonna skip a couple of steps we get the
bounds we just take that chunk of the
raster and then we can create a pot of
all the different bands and using HB
plot we can just say we want X on the x
axis Y on the y axis we want our
particular coordinates reference system
that we've defined above we can say it
the color map our log skill and then we
can also create a plot of the
neighborhood's of those polygons and we
can overlay those two plots using the
star operator which is just how use
terminology for how to overlay plots so
now we've got this pot where we've got
all our neighborhoods and we can see
that we have the correct area so we can
move along with our analysis we're just
going to be looking at the raster data
now so first we're going to calculate
NDVI
so this is the vegetative index so you
can tell where this is the first step
for calculating planet surface
temperature so it's a pretty simple
calculation you just take one band you
subtract from the other so x-ray allows
you to do these calculations really
easily because it keeps tracks of the
labels for you and you can just do your
math and then you can plot it using this
dot hv plot directly on the x-ray object
so now we have our end DVI and then we
can calculate land surface temperature
so there's a couple calculations here
for land surface temperature I just
found them online they seem pretty
straightforward and well well understood
so once you've calculated land surface
temperature you can plot that so you can
calculate land surface temperature for
Banton and band 11 so here we've plotted
them and we've in this case we've
rasterized it so instead of this is a
data shader command so instead of
plotting every single point we're taking
a mean of each pixel and we're plotting
that instead so that makes it
significantly faster and then when you
zoom in it'll be render and you can see
more resolute images so it you don't
lose anything really you just it just
makes it easier to
see or to to actually render so we'll
just take the mean of those and then we
can plot it over some some imagery some
tile service imagery so it's easier to
see actually when we use a threshold
load one so we can look at we can take
just the mean temperature and look at
the values that are over ninety degrees
Fahrenheit and then we can look at just
those values so over here we have those
values and then we have the same plot
linked with the linked with the zoom and
you can see the area the same it's the
same exact data it's just that it's
easier to see it against a white
background and then you can see this the
imagery the tile imagery underneath
three rendering so that's already like
pretty helpful way to explore this data
but I thought it'd be even more nice if
instead of having the threshold just
fixed to 92 to 90 degrees Fahrenheit if
instead we had it be something that the
user could control so that's what we're
gonna be trying to get to in our panel
or dashboard so but first we're gonna
talk a little bit about street trees so
street trees they're this is something
that the city of Philly did they just
had some interns count like located
every tree every city tree one time so
it's like it's getting where I dated but
they did this once and so there's I
think it's a hundred thousand points
it's distributed as a G or JSON so you
can load that right in using geo pandas
and then here I'm just plotting ten
thousand of the points using geo pandas
because it's kind of slow you so you can
use a tree pot directly you can set the
X and the y though geo is true and I've
data shaded it so instead of this is
another data shader command similar to
rasterize who are just counting how many
trees fall in each
each little bin and in this case I've
made it slightly bigger than a pixel so
this is a street tree density and then
just to make it faster for the panel
since they the goj saw these
distributors geo json but they only
filled out the the geometry field so
they only give us latin lon
so I just transformed it into a regular
data frame with a lot of to do longitude
and that makes it just a lot faster so
then we have the so that's the street
tree data and then we save it off as a
parquet file to use in the next okay so
now we're gonna be talking about
creating the dashboard so we're going to
be using the we're gonna load in the
data that we computed from our first
notebook which I stored off in as our
file it's just a good way to store x-ray
objects and then the tree data you store
in the park' file and we're gonna make a
special little color map that only has
reds and it and extreme reds and then
here's a little function that creates a
thresholded plot and it takes a mean
temperature it looks for the values
where the temperature is greater than
threshold and then it calls hv plot on
that with these particular options so it
has tiles underneath it please as we
imagery tiles
it is geo-referenced it has a special
color map it's rasterized so it's faster
so that function will return a plot and
if we call PN a panel interact on that
function and pass in an upper lower and
an upper limit and a step then we'll get
a widget so this mimics the I PI widgets
API if you guys are familiar so it
creates this widget which we can toggle
and control our threshold so you'll see
when I drag it it it kind of flashes
because it's rerender in the whole pot
so that's kind of a limitation of this
approach this this panel that interact
is like a very fast way to get a widget
if you want a widget but it it
recomputes the data every time because
we're subsetting to below the threshold
it reminders the whole plot and it uses
a Python kernel which in this case we
really don't need it's kind of overkill
and we can get it to work in a static
version just with a tiny bit of
JavaScript so first we're going to
define the plot above so this is similar
to what I just did in that function
above and then we're gonna use a clip to
color map so instead of subsetting our
data we're gonna say just anything below
our color map or above our color map
we're gonna make transparent so that's
what this looks like so we're and this
is actually kind of nice because you
still got hover values for all the stuff
that's outside your color map because
there is still data there you just chose
not to look at it and then the next step
is to use javascript linking to link
this is like the the weirdest part
probably of this talk but we're gonna
link the the top of the color map and
the bottom of the code map with the
values that you choose on your widget so
you just this this parts the JavaScript
and you just link that up create a
widget with a start and end value and
then you link it to the color mapper on
the the plot object so now you'll see
that when you when you drag this it it
just rear Enders or it just changes is
very snappy and it doesn't require any
changes to data underneath it's just
changing how it's rendered in JavaScript
and you can see that color map that
color bar moving around while you do
that
so then we'll add in trees so this is a
same tree plot that we did in the last
one and then we just add a toggle to
turn that layer on and off so it's the
same thing where it's just a simpler j/s
link where we're making the the hope the
whole plot invisible basically and then
we'll make a base layer so the tiles
where we're going to use a will use this
widget that that will choose between all
these different tile source options that
are exposed in geo views so we can pick
which tile we want for our base map so
in this case we have as reimage ree but
you can choose other ones and somethings
boring at this at this extent and then
you can add more interaction like
similar alpha sliders and then this is
the actual dashboard that we are
creating so we have a row
the first column is going to be the
threshold slider the Alpha slider base
map selector and then we're gonna have
the plots which we're layering on top of
each other using this star operator so
we're gonna have the temperature plot
the tree plot and the base map plot and
then we're just assigning it to a
variable here and then we can actually
display it and you'll see that you can
interact with it and it's all just the
same as we are looking at originally in
that static page so once you have done
that you can save this as an HTML
document you can and all the parts of it
will work except for the except for the
the tile selector because that is
actually needing a Python back back-end
to change between the different tiles
but you can even embed that if you want
just embed a couple different options
for that
so that is the the most of what I wanted
to talk about I there are some parts I
glossed over so I want to just let you
guys maybe tell me if there's a
particular part that you'd like to see
in more detail I can talk more about the
the parametrize class way of doing
things or anything else I want to open
it up yeah yeah uh you can pip install
it yeah some of the Geo stuff gets a
little wonky like but I think you can
even pip install the Geo stuff yeah but
if you just want panel absolutely if you
just want to intake absolutely it's just
some of the deeper dependencies can get
you know there's some there's some yeah
the Geo stuff in particular is hard to
do without khandha yeah
put on something nice
thank you I'm new to all of you and as I
understood the primary utility of easing
all of you is is enabling you to layer
those BOTS is that correct
um that's so hollow views is the
underlying library that that that allows
you to do HP HP [ __ ]
so when you call H V plot that's just a
thin wrapper that returned that goes to
how I views and ass have used to do a
bunch of stuff and then returns a howl
of use object so the way that I am also
use hall views because I'm a heavy hv
pot user
I like that interface is to do the
overlaying and to do the the linking of
side by side and to get extra options
sometimes but how abuse has its own
whole ideology about how data should be
stored and and how to make it really
easy to visualize data
it's all very laid out on the hall of
use site so I encourage you to look at
that and it might appeal to you for me
that I was more comfortable with the dot
plot API and that's that some it just
works better for me but um hall of use
aspires to let you just annotate your
data and then it should be able to like
visualize itself is the hall of use
premise so it's more than that but
that's just how I use it
I think it's good I think yes
Peter Clarke Julia so can you maybe
explain that relationship being
you system for that all the HP's up here
and voila and like how those are going
together yeah so um voila for people who
maybe aren't familiar is the Jupiter
dashboarding solution so panel is a
dashboarding solution that can work in
Jupiter and also works outside of
Jupiter but envoie is a is a Jupiter it
was developed by Jupiter folks and it
works in Jupiter exclusively right and I
think at this time or very soon panel
can work in voila
and all the Hall of you stuff can work
in voila and we're trying to get the
other direction working as well I don't
think that's quite done yet so that the
goal is that everyone can just play nice
together and people don't have to worry
about it it's not quite there yet the
same as I pie widgets is the same deal
as we would like to have a pie widgets'
included in our in our dashboards and
we're very close to having that be a
reality
any more question
thanks this is great eclis let's say I'm
terrible JavaScript yeah yeah so okay so
there's I talked about a bunch of
different packages in this talk so a lot
of them fall under the hull of is
umbrella and so if you want to learn
more about all the VIS things you saw
that is holidays and you can just start
there it's it's viz with us with a Z it
matters actually so it's just holidays
org and you can start from there
but they also all have their own package
specific Docs panel it has very good
docs and there's a whole section about
JavaScript linking where it taught it
goes through the most common uses if
you're really getting into it you just
have to like do a lot of printing this
is the main thing that you have to do to
figure out what exactly you have to work
with and once you do that you can it's
fairly straightforward to figure out
what's going on
because more about life updating of the
content that we display um yeah so I
mean it's just it's just changing so
bouquet has a Python side and a
JavaScript side and in this case we're
just fiddling with the JavaScript itself
and controlling it with this slider so
it's just changing the changing what's
actually being viewed so it's just how
every website works basically right so
it doesn't have a Python instance so
it's very quick I'm not entirely sure
about streaming it I guess it depends
how you are getting that data in most of
the examples I've seen with streaming
data use the task streams library and
that would require a Python yeah
because I'm excited about using that
yeah any troubleshooting tips for intake
will definitely reach out to us if you
have like seriously um we're on intake
there's a get ur like you know don't
hesitate to do that we want to know what
people are struggling with we want to
know what people are using it for so
please do that or if you think you've
run into a bug like file it also if you
have suggestions like there are docs on
intake but that we are always open to
suggestions if you think that there's
something that you can't figure out from
the docs and then you figure it out
great like open a Doc's PR or tell us
you know write up a github issue or
something yeah I don't it's hard to say
what the debugging techniques are other
than a lot of times I start at the top
doing like an open parque or open X
x-ray or something and before I write
the catalogue just get all the arguments
like fleshed out that way it's so
tableau is very like drag and drop you
right and it's very slow okay so like
maybe it's not as slow
[Music]
no I mean I don't think we're really
quite aspiring to be Tablo but the idea
with this is that you are creating
dashboards for people to interact with
your data and you customize that
experience for them I don't have much
familiarity with tableau so I can't
probably do a good comparison but my
understanding is also that tableau is
mostly for only tabular data possibly
and we really have a have a almost maybe
too strong geo data influence in our
team so we are very attuned to the needs
of n dimensional data we work a lot with
x-ray data and we've really put the
focus on that so it's you can do tabular
data we try to make it as nice as
possible but you're not you're not
confined to these like tiny data sets
you can also have other stuff because
you probably do yeah
so I've seen that there are also other
patents beyond go game that are
supported or all of those both other
backends also cervical um yeah yeah you
can put a you can put any to have your
plot you want in a panel op that's your
question right yep yeah you can put any
type of plot you want right now HV plot
only supports bouquet but that's there's
no reason for that it's just time but
Hall of you supports partly matplotlib
and bouquet
all right Julia thank you very much
[Applause]